the first of the so-called space
billionaires
left earth's atmosphere yesterday in a
historic moment for commercial space
travel
sir richard branson rode on a virgin
galactic
suborbital test flight he became the
first person to reach space
in his own ship so crazy more than a
week ahead of jeff bezos and his blue
origin rocket
mark strossman is at spaceport america
in new mexico where branson took off and
landed
mark you've been reporting on this space
race for years and years
what was it like finally seeing one of
these billionaires take flight
well good morning adriana it was it was
exhilarating to watch it really was so
you can imagine
how exhilarating it must have felt to be
high above earth and going through all
of this i mean richard branson will tell
you
that exhilaration is now available to
anyone the access to space
is there if you have the money to pay
for it
to the next generation of dreamers if we
can do
this just imagine what you can do
[Music]
more than 53 miles above earth richard
branson was
walking on air or something close to it
giddy
in microgravity a tourist at the edge of
space
it's a complete experience on sunday
the 70 year old knighted billionaire
became the first space baron to ride
out of earth's atmosphere ahead of
billionaire jeff bezos
was it important to be first honestly no
come on
not at all honestly no we've been at
both at this for about 20 years
it it really doesn't didn't matter
whether one of us went up before the
other we need
many many many many spaceships so many
many people can enjoy this
wherever he travels branson brings
swaggering style
astronaut one
license to thrill his live streamed
space adventure was a marketing bonanza
virgin galactic his space company plans
to fly wannabe astronauts
a closed waiting list of more than 600
people have pre-paid 250
000 apiece for a joyride into the cosmos
but do you have the sense that this
business is truly
viable if you can't bring the price down
there are just so many people
if you ask 10 people you'll find
seven out of 10 would love to go to
space the market is gigantic
but we will be able to bring the price
down and you know it
like with commercial aviation travel
it'll take a few years
and and the wealthy will will pay the
bills and enable us to do that
branson's maiden space flight came on
virgin galactic's mothership
a twin fuselage plane named eve after
his late mother eve carried the tethered
space plane called
unity eight and a half miles above earth
then let go
release release release clean release
ignition sending unity rocketing into
space
with branson on board the total trip
took an
hour plus the nearly 20 years of grit to
evolve virgin galactic
to this moment sir richard branson
astronauts but branson finally has his
astronaut wings of all your trophies in
life where does that
astronaut pin rank i i would say it's um
the most important trophy it was a
culmination i suspected
a lot of wonderful adventures and a lot
of work and
yeah i'm still floating branson hopes to
be flying his first paying customer
sometime next year
this flight really did seem to go
flawlessly and gail the future of space
tourism
needed it to i'll say mark it was so
cool thank you so much
you know branson said that he's dreamt
of this as a child but when it happens
you really
can't describe it he said it was magical
and beautiful
he was giddy like a kid it was fun to
watch one of the things that was so
special about the whole thing was seeing
how much he
really enjoyed i thought so too i really
enjoyed it he said yay when he took off
his heat felt so he could float in the
air
and as scared as i am you know i think i
could never do that there was something
about them being able to float in space
and the way they did it that i thought
almost makes you want to go doesn't it
gail
a little bit there's still time but no
time soon
even branson said he's not going to do
anything anytime soon he doesn't want to
put his family through that
anytime soon but congratulations yes sir
richard branson well done well done sir